the Joker Lex Luthor General Zod
doomsday you can forget them all here
are nine reasons why Deathstroke is a
perfect choice to battle Batman on the
big screen number nine Deathstroke is a
no-nonsense villain known as Deathstroke
the Terminator Slade Wilson isn't
someone that messes around he conducts
business on his own terms when the evil
organization hive hired him to destroy
the Teen Titans he insisted on getting
paid up front this wasn't the way hive
did things so he was ready to walk they
opened fire on him but he quickly showed
them just how skilled he was lucky for
them they weren't in a room as he was
ready to kill them all
number eight Deathstroke has enhanced
abilities Slade Wilson is extremely
skilled at everything he does in fact he
has quite an advantage when taken on the
likes of Batman in the army he
volunteered to be part of an experiment
to make metahuman soldiers this gave him
heightened strength stamina speed
endurance and a jacked up healing factor
his brain power was also increased
making him a tactical genius number
seven Deathstroke fights dirty when it
appeared he might be outgunned by the
alien Starfire he knew placing innocence
at risk would divert her attention
Deathstroke's goal is to win and he'll
do whatever it takes to complete his
task bottom line he's not afraid to use
civilians as leverage against the noble
ideals of superheroes number six
Deathstroke knows how to uncover secrets
after fighting the Teen Titans on
numerous occasions he came up with a way
to infiltrate the team sending in a
young and diabolical hero as a mole she
soon won two hearts as a team and
reported their secret identities to
Wilson Deathstroke is extremely
resourceful in mining Intel and his
enemies and using the information to his
advantage should it suit his needs
number five Deathstroke fought and
defeated Batman that's right in 1991's
Deathstroke number seven Deathstroke and
Batman fought the two were both after
the same man but differed on how to
target should be dealt with
no surprise here Deathstroke wanted the
man dead so he and Batman quickly came
to blows the brawl was intense and
proved just how formidable Slade can be
in fact when it came to hand-to-hand
combat Batman didn't stand a chance
number four Deathstroke also fought
Superman the Man of Steel is a far more
powerful opponent than Batman sure
Deathstroke has enhance abilities but
nowhere near that of Superman in the
comics this didn't stop Slade using some
quick thinking and reflexes Deathstroke
eluded the Kryptonian something few have
been able to do of course having a
magical sword made by the Greek gods
blacksmith was a big help
this shows he's not dumb enough to jump
into a fight without the proper
equipment number three
Deathstroke fought the entire Justice
League that's exactly what happened in
2004's
identity crisis number three Deathstroke
took out elongated man the flash Satana
Hawkman Green Arrow
Black Canary Adam and Green Lantern
impressive right
it wasn't until Green Arrow shoved an
arrow into his empty eye socket that a
team could recover from his attack and
subdue him number two we need a fresh
face to take on Batman Batman has a
really great rogues gallery the problem
is we've seen some of them multiple
times on a big screen and there's still
a bad taste in our mouths over some of
them you lie there have been three
different Joker's four if you count
Cesar Romero two different Catwoman
three if you count Halle Berry which no
one does two different two faces and two
different Bane's Deathstroke is an
opportunity to give audiences a Batphone
we have yet to see on screen number one
current movie Batman needs a more brutal
enemy in a departure from the comics our
current Caped Crusader has no problem
taking lives maybe it's because he's a
more hardened hero who suffered personal
losses after decades of crime-fighting
this is exactly why Batman needs a
villain he can cut loose on in
Deathstroke we have a character that
will give Batman a run for his money
with his enhanced abilities skills and
technical prowess
Batman versus destro will be a glorious
battle to witness let's just hope they
can come up the better title for the
film